picturesque Coburg in bavaria the town's
striking coat of arms depicts the so
called more of Coburg the emblem is now
at the center of a heated controversy
opponents call it a symbol of racism but
many residents are mystified is there
really nothing else to worry about we've
got bigger problems than the Coburg more
he's the patron saint of Coburg and i
find this whole discussion out of order
never upset anyone it can stay as it is
the crest dates back to the Middle Ages
when black people were often described
as Moors today the term is viewed as
derogatory but it's not intended to be
demeaning according to Coburg historian
who Burtis harbor the emblem features
saint mauritius a black Christian knight
who was martyred and is now commemorated
in Japan is desperate to that extent I
think the word more is okay and the
representation of a black man as the
symbol of Coburg is absolutely fine it's
an expression of esteem and veneration
for the saint for the smiling constant
that's not a view shared by two young
Berliners who've started an online
petition against Co Berg's coat of arms
Alicia
Archie is originally from the area for
her calling a black man amor is no
longer acceptable in the light of the
black lives matter movement and
especially not a figure with thick lips
and a Caribbean style earring that
suggests to some that all black people
and all Africans look the same a
complete nonsense for a continent where
people look totally different from one
another
others find something exotic in it a
ferocity that has to do with savage
people's it's a racist portrayal that
should not be allowed to continue
and quieter antha mich mayor stephanie
the town council is irritated by the
debate and is not giving any interviews
on the subject of the coat of arms the
answer could be just to change the
description says this resident he's got
a name after all mauritius why shouldn't
it be the Coburg Mauritius Mauritius
pharmacy Mauritius Street that sounds
better
how do you measure culture what is
racist it's not easy to find the right
balance especially not in Coburg